riesen atom tatsächlich zum ersten mal
im weltall hergestellt das ganze nennt
sich wo wie einstein kondensat und es
war für mich spezielles und im weltall
materie wellen interferometrie unter
schwerelosigkeit kurzem 11 dafür ist ein
experiment der forscher unter anderem
vom deutschen zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt und der universität hannover
erfolgreich durchgeführt haben
dahinter steckt jetzt wirklich zum
science fiction minus 273 15 grad
versetzt das ist der absolute nullpunkt
und wenn man atome eines gases annähernd
so tief herunterkühlt dann befinden sie
sich in einem extremen aggregatzustand
wie sind ein bose-einstein-kondensat
kurz gk das besondere daran ist dass ich
diese atome wie ein einziges atom
verhalten und dieser atomkomplex
schwingt dann wellenartig im gleichtakt
das bedeutet dass man in dieser akt oben
wollte kein einzelnes atom mehr
ausmachen kann
sie sind eins geworden atome in diesen
zustand zu versetzen ist bereits nach
der 95 gelungen mit hilfe einer
komplexen apparatur die auf einer atom
falle magneten und lesern zur kühlung
bestand 2007 ist es dann sogar mit einer
gerätschaft bewerkstelligt worden die
nicht größer als ein handelsüblicher
kühlschrank ist jetzt ist den forschern
ein weiterer durch kopplung wie haben
diese kühlschrank große apparatur ins
all geflogen am anfang januar startete
eine ballistische rakete vom
norwegischen esrange dienst als 100 bose
einstein kondensat dort zu erschaffen
gab es ein zeitfenster von lediglich
sechs minuten in diesen sechs minuten
hat sich die rakete in einem
schwerelosen zustand befunden
mit hilfe der laser wurden die bewegung
der moleküle der atomwolke zunächst
vermindert dadurch erfolgte eine
abkühlung fast bis zum absoluten
nullpunkt in einem zweiten schritt
siebten magnetfelder atome die noch zu
warm waren heraus es war geschafft die
rubidium atome waren in diesen
besonderen aggregatzustand übergegangen
die tat nun sind glücklich dass wir
nachweisen konnten dass die -1 anlage im
weltraum einwandfrei arbeitet
während der schwerelosigkeit farbe
konnten rund 100 einzel experimente zu
verschiedenen aspekten der materie
wellen interferometrie durchgeführt
werden so rainer volk vom raumfahrt
management des deutschen zentrums für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr ist dieser
erfolg zb für die spätere erforschung
von gravitation oder für den bau von
präzisen quanten sensoren für die
navigation
wenn ihr euch für verheerende super
sonnenstürme die die erde treffen werden
interessiert dann geht es genau hier zum
video also mit dem anklicken kein video
mehr verpassen hier kostenlos abonnieren
und die glocke anklicken nach oben den
daumen wenn video geführt hat zum
erstaunen bei welche extra intrigieren
euch noch so schreibt es mir in die
kommentare und ansonsten mit morgen und
bis dann bleibt dran